[Musique]
jeudi
tian bonjour ça va je suis pourtant
devoir rester en forme
moi aussi ça va merci pourquoi parfois
et ça pousse menaces casimir ça va ouais
pause - la question quelle question
tu sais à propos mal son arrivée parce
que tu veux que aller avec pose même la
question au monde d'accord mais tu t'en
as un bon niveau puis de casimir casimir
casimir au casimir cas qu'est ce que
c'est c'est moi françois tu veux que je
te pose la question c'est bien son ouais
et alors et bah alors où le serait
difficile bon on y va casimir comment
s'est passée la leçon de chant aa bien
très bien c'est fini c'est vrai tu veux
dire que du set à chansons par coeur
ouais sur monsieur formidable saga
zémire tu veux que je la chante
séverine à bien voir une surprise
j'arrive j'étais content vous allez être
les premiers à entendre la chanson de
casimir alors cette surprise qu'est ce
que c'est eh bien je sais ma chanson
complètement way qui nous lâchent enfin
oui tout de suite
allez on survit 1 on y va on your heart
on
et que se passe-t-il ici à messieurs du
snob vous tombez bien
casini on va nous chanter sa chanson
mais cela est passionnant non je
t'écoute mon bon casimir bon allez vous
êtes prêt en effet les enfants
oui on va pas chanter sur les intentions
des enfants rené ruelle est venue du
notw olivier meilhac mme olivier casimir
25 ans de chansons tu verras mieux tout
le monde est prêt le verdict à des
meilleurs chante non non non c'est pas
possible tu sais ta chanson ouais et
alors elle est jolie
bah ouais et alors sommes là pour
t'écouter bon et alors alors il faut
chanter casimir
non non et pourquoi pourquoi parce que
personne ne me l'a demandé gentiment aux
fais moi plaisir casimir chante la
chanson s'il te plaît d'accord on y va
alors très attention hein
[Musique]
avec une chanson imagine
je vous en prie
[Musique]
le soyez terrorisés je suis le monde
ribéry
je m'appelle casimir
[Musique]
aussi tout cas l'enjeu
si l'on m'a dit à moi
je sais jouer de la musique
je suis gay et ce
à dire gamine si j'aime la glace aux
anchois c'est bon droit c'est moi m'a
vite qu'une chanson
un peu imaginent
je vous armer nos dans notre it is du
bonheur tranquille
ces couleurs rencontrer ne soyez pas
terrorisé je suis le monstre du berry
je m'appelle casimir j'ai une machine
avec une idée fantastique
je mange eux
gloubiboulga à la campagne j'ai vu la
montagne au cinéma méga
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est magique
mais nous n'en est rien
de manière en pis
m
soyez
je suis le bon sens qui fait rire
[Musique]
casini
ah bon